hi I'm Mark Ruffalo and this is how I
became Rob a lot becoming Rob a lot was
appealing to me because because he was
an atypical hero he's a guy who is part
of a corporate defense company that
decides to take on a case for a farmer
that he knew really well he was growing
up against DuPont the biggest chemical
company in the world and he ends up
uncovering the biggest contamination and
poisoning of the world from this one
little case DuPont is knowingly
poisoning 70,000 local residents for the
last 40 years my first impression of Rob
a lot was somebody that was very modest
soft-spoken thoughtful and very gentle
something very sweet in him even though
he was you know taking on this this
corporate giant which made it a really
interesting kind of character and not
what you would think of as somebody who
tackles something as enormous as he does
in this in his film I spent days with
Rob a lot one of our first meetings I
was meeting at the Taft building in
Cincinnati we were meeting at a
particular time and I showed up a little
bit early and I got to observe him for
maybe 10 minutes without him knowing
that I was there and I watched him I
actually followed him he was walking
around and I I was just regarding the
way he walked and the way moved and you
know he was on set with me all the time
I would call him all hours of the night
to ask him things about like you know
what kind of snacks did you eat during
this what did you put in your coffee to
why why would you continue on something
so difficult and lonely and alienating
for so long but there was a lot of
questions that I had
about motivation because this guy what
he did was so antithetical to what most
of us think it is to be successful in
America here he was in this giant
important law firm that defended the
biggest companies in the world and he
was working on behalf of a cow farmer in
in West Virginia who had a 12th grade
education and he completely left the
American ideal of success to go down
this other more just and I would say
although he's not openly spiritual or
talks about spirit was a spiritual path
for righteousness and I wanted to know
why well you know what compel somebody
to do that and I don't know that ever
really got to the to the bottom of that
question other than there's just
something that he he had a greater
belief in justice than he did in in
things in material these companies they
have all the money all the time and
they'll use it trust me I know I was one
of them you're still one of them there's
a scene that was particularly hard for
me and and challenging was the scene
when Rob is has the kind of the
breakdown his physical body just sort of
breaks down underneath the pressure and
I don't understand that I've never
experienced anything like that so to
make that work and to and to have it be
believable was it was something that I
can't and I was struggling with a lot
and I had a hard time shooting I
probably shot that probably six times
then there's there's a couple scenes
there's like there's a probably a six
page monologue where he he basically
lays out the entire history of Teflon
and c8 and that that was challenging to
to be able to tell that story and to do
it in a way that
has the same kind of thoughtfulness that
Rob has and not as an actor try to go
for like the big emotional speech but
but be as honest as possible to who rob
a lot was that that's challenging and
that takes a lot of discipline and and
it takes some some bit of courage as
well I mean I'm not so it was hard for
me you want to take everything that you
know and turn it against an iconic
American company like an informant isn't
that right yes I'm inspired by David and
Goliath stories because we all sort of
relate to them we all understand this
dynamic so well and we oddly identify
with the with the David we understand
that we're living under an oppressive
kind of system at times and we always
want the little guy to be able to beat
this this monster this giant and I just
think it's great storytelling and it's a
story telling that we really we really
understand somewhere deep inside of us
in a really simple way the system is
rigged they want us to think it'll
protect us we protect us we do